Niagara Falls has approximately eight million visitors a year.
We have the falls itself. We have Buffalo.
We have Toronto. We have great state-of-the-art schools and lovely parks.
The home listing report certainly shows that Niagara Falls property is of value.
In addition to that, we have great community spirit neighborhoods and quality of life.
We certainly see quite a few first-time home buyers.
The fact is, because housing is so affordable,...
...they can choose to purchase rather than rent...
...and that makes it special for them.
Niagara Falls in western New York is not only just an affordable place to live,...
...it's a wonderful, wonderful place for you to raise your families.
In Niagara Falls, of course, have the falls themselves...
...and the iconic Maid of the Mist and Cave of the Winds tours,...
...as well as just walk around Niagara Falls State Park, which is beautiful in itself.
The best thing about living in our area is certainly the people.
People in western New York are wonderful, supportive, strong, and proud,...
...just a great place to live in western New York.